when i was in china i spent my entire
school years
in the chinese cultural revolution so
i'm very very familiar with the
communist tactics of how they divide
people how they cancel the chinese
traditional culture and destroy our
heritage and all this is happening here
in america
now they are labeling parents
and concerned citizens like me as
domestic
terrorists what that can do
you may lose your freedom i do have a
question what's next step
is the t admin square crack down
the next
would parents one day
risk their life
just to speak up for their children
that's why i'm here it's not just a
chill it's it's freezing you know you're
not chilling the first amendment you are
freezing parents in place about whether
to even show up at a school board
meeting you know
some school boards are requesting
identification and they're wanding
people like they're going through a tsa
checkpoint to show up to speak on behalf
of their children i i think it's
intimidation no doubt about it you know
so they called them racists
for a long time but that did not work so
they have to upgrade to domestic
terrorists but i have to say this will
backfire if the intimidation works
american has fallen long time ago i i
could not believe in america which is
supposed to be the land of liberty um
somebody
could
target parents like this parents we are
the primary educators for our children
no one can take our place and to tell us
that we have the audacity to speak up
for our children
was shocking to say the least now now
parents are acting in fear
and
and i can understand parents not wanting
to speak in front of the school board
members are they concerned because now
there is a fear they've instilled fear
within the parents they created fear
amongst the community in which they're
supposed to serve as the support i am
scared yet i believe that i'm living in
a time when if i don't speak up for my
child and if i don't stand up for what's
right in america
um
i don't know what the next generation
will be left with in china the school
the public school
are really government school
and here
is the same thing is happening here
the radical left has already taken over
our educational system
they control the schools the school
board
and other associations such as teacher
association and national
school board association
and they actually have been training our
children to be the social justice
warriors
for a long time
just because a parent speaks angrily
from a podium in front of you
for first three minutes and then they
cut it down to two minutes if they speak
angrily to you
that's their right they're your boss and
the organization chart has been flipped
where they feel like they are in charge
of us
and i think it is responsible for
citizens to stand up and speak up about
how their taxpayer dollars are spent
because even if they don't have children
in the public school system
your money still goes to school i think
they need to write to the legislatures i
think they need to realize that that
elections do matter you need to vote for
new school board members the school
board is probably the most important
election that a person could vote in
outside of the you know for the
presidency in the united states don't be
intimidated this is not
about
um some some right this is about your
children your own children and for me
this i'm fighting it because it's about
our future the future of this country so
we cannot be intimidated